-Hey!
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
Hey!
♪♪
-Whoo-hoo!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
Can you just make yourself
visible, already?
[ Whoosh ]
-What?
Why didn't he do that sooner?
-I don't know.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with David Harbour.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "We Have a Ghost."
Now, I think it's very clear
from that clip you play a ghost.
Usually, when we show a clip
from one of the stars
of a film who's here,
we make sure that clip
has lines from them,
but you don't have a single line
in this movie.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I have some --
I improvised some moans.
-Yeah? Oh, they let you
do a few moans?
-[ Moans ]
-Oh, very good.
-Thank you.
-Very well cast.
-Yeah, no lie.
They sent me the script.
And it was, you know, "You are
one of the leads of this movie,
walking around, doing things,
being a ghost,
and you have no lines."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I was like, "Yes!
-I mean, so, so nice, right?
-Easy gig.
-Yeah.
-And it's a great cast.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anthony Mackie.
-Who's wonderful.
-He's great. I love him.
Also this younger actor,
Jahi Winston, who I think
is really special.
Like, really soulful kid.
I really liked him.
-That's really cool
to work with people like that
you never met before.
You also worked
with Jennifer Coolidge.
-Yes, Jennifer Coolidge, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she is as amazing
as you think she would be.
-Yeah. In person, she's
everything you want her to be.
-Yeah.
-It's really great.
-It's just what you see
on a talk show
or at an awards show.
It just is that.
And it's not that way
with some of us.
[ Laughter ]
But, the -- yeah.
She was incredible.
She's so funny.
There's one scene --
I don't think
I'm spoiling the film.
It's not like Marvel here.
But there is a scene in the film
where I frighten her.
And she runs screaming
and jumps out a window.
And you think, like,
in the script,
it just says, like, "Runs
screaming out the window."
I swear, there were like --
we did about 15 takes.
And every take, she was like,
"Let's try it again."
[ Laughter ]
"Maybe I could go like this.
'Ooh, ooh, ooh!'"
It's like I've never seen any --
every animal, every sound was --
it was a lesson.
-Yeah.
-It was an acting class.
-If there's any actor
who thought through 15 ways
to jump out a window,
I'm happy it's her.
[ Laughter ]
-She also had this amazing --
We have this amazing moment
where there's a CGI thing
that shoots out of my face,
and it's a hand
and it strangles her.
And you know,
so I did it with my hand.
I just, like -- and
she was, like, really pissed.
We stopped the take.
And she was like,
"David, you got to
really strangle me.
You got to strangle me!"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Jen, you're --
You know, what do you --
I'm not gonna murder
America's sweetheart."
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "Come on! Come on!"
-Well, I'm glad
you didn't murder her.
I'm glad you trusted
your own instincts.
-Yeah.
-One last thing
I want to ask you.
No details, no spoilers.
But I know you're about
to embark on the final --
you're filming your last
of "Stranger Things".
-Yeah.
-What an incredible journey
it must be to watch
not just this show take off
but also to watch
all those kids grow up.
-Yeah, yeah.
It'll be really special.
We go back in, I think,
May or June.
And we shoot the final season.
And you know, it's been,
at this point, eight years.
It'll be 10 years of my life
by the time that wraps.
And so -- And you know, it did
everything for me, that show.
It created a whole new career
for me.
-And we've all been
the beneficiaries of it.
It's been so cool how many
people in that show
we didn't know before
that we got to see
for the first time and
then see everywhere else.
Man, it is just always
such a pleasure
to have you here.
Thank you so much, David.
-Thanks.
-David Harbour!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"We Have a Ghost" premieres
February 24th on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with Kathryn Newton.